so you guys uh you guys have been going
crazy uh since the last time you were
here obviously y'all were going crazy
last time you were here but now y'all
got a song going crazy on the radio
how's it feel like get in the car and
turn turn the [__] on and your shit's
playing it feel good now every time I
see it I start smiling like ay feeling
adorable radio yeah what's Walky
mean please put me up on your guyses BR
yeah like that's a crazy mean is Walky
is the that drip okay so if like y'all
are Walky right now with the drip walk
is like drink not even bro no I know
walk is like like like actual lean right
like yeah yeah yeah that's Walky but and
F son is crazy like wow that's Walky Wy
that's wild that [__] Walky like it can
be good it can be
bad so it's like got multiple
applications yeah basically like your
sprite's real walky
or yo you look at Dum Walky right now
yeah you could say somebody look walk if
but for me it could be good walk or bad
walk what about a Jabba huh what do
y'all think about them what the [__] is
a Jabba they're dancers they're Asians
oh the [__] not be wearing a mask yes
yo them [__] nice where my dad what's
a jab walkie bro the [__] the real
walkies the the real walkies bro wearing
the mask bro the white mask N I got to
see you know them I don't bro what about
aren't there walkies in Star Wars
there's walkies in Star Wars I I ain't
watch Star Wars I you guys have never
seen Star Wars was for for the weirdos
growing up what the [__] does that mean
where the [__] did y'all watch as kid
Star Wars Star Wars is for the School
shooters bro what Star Wars is for
School shooters inate Star Wars is for
the school Jen are you cosigning the
school shooter Star Wars correlation
anime was for the weirdos too yeah I was
never watching I only watched one anime
bro and that [__] was that fire what I
used to watch a little bit of Dragon
Ball Z but that [__] was like Dragon
Ball Z was acceptable yeah acceptable I
watch the
travs you've never seen them a you mean
mes they dance bro they dance bro
they're like [__] sick ass dancers
they got they got a Vegas show is nice
bro
yo moms they were jacking for
sure what
what I'm hey man I'm just trying to I'm
just trying to you know I'm just trying
to see what they're I'm trying to you
know get down with the Brownsville lingo
my apologies that was bad Jes guess I
[__] missed that one by a th000 miles
got so no Star Wars you guys ever watch
Lord of the Rings
oh the star Boy watch that commercial
Harry Potter Harry Potter I tried to
watch Harry Potter like it I could have
grabbed like you ever watch Percy
Jackson oh the um that was kind like
Harry Potter and [__] huh I know what
you talking about I watch that [__] but
Harry Potter with the gods right like
all those type of shows for the serial
killers Bro [__] what ter you got to
chill bro I guess I'm
seral nigg to be wild what's y'all's
favorite Disney movie oh um Let It Shine
gangster I don't even know what that is
uh
it I'm sorry what says the guys who
ain't never seen [__] Star Wars
judging me you want know letter Sean
Google that [__] what the [__] is it
letter Shine the mov with the rap [__]
yes what you talking about Roxy I'm
sorry you about that yeah I like to oh
this okay what's y' favorite hey bro
this I what is a what y''s favorite
cartoon Disney movie yeah I said Toy
Story this is a live action is the guy
story definitely got it story fire
Disney pixx
Disney which one the real one to St was
fire Cella was fire Cinderella huh nice
I like cars princess in the frog
princess the frog is amazing what those
cars is fire you guys ever watch record
Ralph that was my favorite movie that my
favorite movie bro that's that
[__] why you why do you why do you
relate to Ralph cuz he's like he's
misunderstood
which one big big yeah yeah that was on
Disney solid very underrated movie is
tough you guys ever watch Wally W was
myit used to make me cry my heart us
they Val
some and it's so good cuz it's got no
it's really no talking in it it's just
like w it's like the [__] and the [__]
robot and the dude robot you know and
they like you know shout what's the
what's the name Eva EV is it Eve or Eva
I forgot I think it was Eva yeah yeah
great movie I watch W if we got to go to
the movies today bro y'all horing some
new movie dad just came out is there a
new movie I don't know mad new [__] just
came out I just watched uh what's the
last movie I saw I don't even know the
exorcism came out I heard that show was
mad scary yeah you didn't see the OG one
I don't really like scary movies nah I
feel you you like you guys like scary
movies I do what do you like what what's
your favorite uh insidious insidious
that's a y the last Insidious yo the
last Conjuring that they dropped was
wild scary I feel like scary you don't
like scary movies Jen n i don't I
wouldn't watch it on my own I I never
watched a scary movie on my own can you
turn your mic towards your mouth PA yeah
I never yeah I don't really watch scary
movies on my own bro we group out in
cool I'll do scary what about saw yo we
about to go watch
yesterday they just dropped a new one
they brought the dude back the dude died
a million [__] times and somehow he's
[__] back again I don't get it it's
[__] crazy you guys while you're out
here you guys need to go to Halloween
Horror Nights at Universal Studios
Halloween Horror Nights yo we supposed
to go there last night
bro the [__] was telling me to go there
I was fight F bro [__] guys chasing
you around we out we out y'all be Hing
[__] don't want to listen wait what
does that mean if someone's horsing [__]
you just snotted all over the mic don't
get that [__] don't get that was a that
was a lot of [__] he
said I see it it's hanging on the mic
cord holy
yo son just went crazy on with the the
booger just flew yo sh look like anyways
[__] just went viral for me nah we a
go viral what's Hing mean I want to see
on the internet what am I horing mean
like like like to me like you like uh
mean you horing bro horing mean like
youing like if you're [__] a [__] or
you horing you L gag oh Lolly gagging
okay see you're speaking all white guy
language you're [__] Lolly gagging
bro [__] Lolly gagging with me
[__] Lolly gagging bro [__]
shito gang around what is it Gangster I
put gangster at the end of all my sent
it's like it's like a period basically
it's like but like it can start a
sentence too ganger has mad meaning I
mean I'm aware that one I'm pretty hip
to you know I'm not a [__] I'm not a
total weenie I'm saying like in New York
we say yeah I think they say ganga a lot
everywhere all the time but wait we're
not calling somebody gangster we're just
saying gangster is there anything
Brownsville specific y'all say that's
only like people would only know if
they're from your area Brooklyn it's a
lot of
[__] NY grew
too grew I ain't going lie that's some
new [__]
though what some Spanish [__] that ass I
mean it's really like some Spanglish
[__] nice
yeah